spring is traditionally one of the
driest seasons when it comes to new
games but this isn't necessarily a bad
thing keeping in line with the
expectations there weren't a lot of new
games in April but there were some gems
that rose to the top going toe-to-toe
with a big-budget game and totally
holding their own box boy on the 3ds
doesn't look like much from the outside
but it's simple mechanics and puzzles
expand gradually over time testing your
intellect just enough to consistently
deliver a strong sense of satisfaction
affordable space adventures also caught
our attention by making great use of the
Wii U's gamepad to facilitate teamwork
as you explore the beautiful and
mysterious far-off reaches of deep space
crypt of the necrodancer took a dungeon
crawling to new depths melding roguelike
elements with mechanics from rhythm
games offering an experience unlike
anything that we played before though it
technically came out in March we
reviewed pillars of eternity in April so
the impressive amaj to baldur's gate was
also among our short list of candidates
but these games are proof that any time
of the year can be a good time for games
as usual it was difficult to choose our
game at the Month for April that the
award ultimately goes to the robust
Mortal Kombat X the core of the mortal
combat experience remains largely the
same in MK x you fight against an
opponent in a violent bout replete with
blood moans of pain and over-the-top
finishing moves alongside some fresh
faces classic characters from the past
return true to form when an extensive
story mode the details their struggles
the fighting system has
never felt so fluid either and the added
depth of character variations makes one
character feel like three giving you
more to explore and learn and more for
your opponents to worry about Mortal
Kombat X delivers the series
characteristic violence in such a
captivating and entertaining way leaning
on absurdity wherever possible to great
effect you cringe at the sight and sound
of flesh tearing and bones breaking but
you can't help but laugh when the act is
punctuated with the timely quip MKX is a
great fighting experience with deep
mechanics a big game with no shortage of
challenges and modes to explore and a
tour de force of brutality that's
enhanced by the game's impressive
visuals the rest of our candidates and
no doubt great games but the honour of
game of the month belongs to m KX